ça va bien merci d'être là c'est d'être
de plus en plus belle un franchement
droit ça vous fait rien non mais si
c'est ce qui c'est étouffer
des mois oui j'ai regardé l'émission
mardi ya mardi avec ou mardi c'est
vraiment gad elmaleh c'est vraiment gad
elmaleh ah bah oui oui bah oui oui ben
arfa qui tapait qui paye archers de le
rappeler il faut que je l'appelle
d'ailleurs gaouaoui temps là parce qu'à
un moment un moment donné je me suis dit
se son pote yann qu'attend non yann
katanga en coulisses et qui fait une
blague non non sérieux c'est le vrai gad
elmaleh we get de casa de coco de
chouchou tout ça avais tu vois ça c'est
pas possible pourquoi parce que c'est
pas possible de prendre des appels perso
pendant l'émission regardez qui font que
ça tes camarades ben oui est ce qui
prend des appels de leurs copains
pendant l'émission isabelle qu'un est-ce
qu'elle prend à iqaluit
n'appelle pas de ouf non plus
bernard montiel est ce qu'il prend
brigitte macron
nom benjamin castaldi
benjamins ils feront jamais personne à
son téléphone c'est juste pour se
maquiller bon bref c'est pas ça
[Rires]
valérie nos poches mon père et moi avons
pris une grande décision on va te
confisqué son téléphone donne moi ton
téléphone
raconté les fans beaucoup itunes est
bonne à baïji courage commence à
beaucoup aussi d'enlever votre téléphone
qui a déjà essayé de me confisque
d'attenté les fans déjà donné vous
téléphonez pas donné la date
n est pas là bas tu mets raison
on a du mal avec courage à dire
à l'eau
et compte séduire les près de toi il
faut il dire obama
c'est quelqu'un pour toi
[Musique]
tu vas me casser longtemps
tu vois pas qui est occupée renom
plainte et pnc
ont dû
casser
avec un seul étant important
je sais qu'il sera le président
on connait le battre les candidats
durant contre n importe quoi elles
seraient émis tombe à la casse toi
le droit il faut lui dire obama
c'est marlène schiappa
oui bien sûr est depuis comment l'aja
pavois sera devant son foetus et marlon
je viens quand tu es dans l'émission
c'est pas la peine de faire mes
imitations l'accord ont dû est un que je
suis moi je sortis en bout
et j'en prends pas c'est méchant c'est
pas vrai
les nîmois
temps qu'elle
il faut
[Musique]
on ne pleure
dernier
obéit mois
[Musique]
ah bah ouais
non tu m'as
ça s'est passé
[Applaudissements]
tout est verrouillé c'est la barrière
fois je leur ai pas
un numéro très chaud nous qui
m'appellent et sage et alors
[Rires]
jean 46 feed coup courbe j'ai regardé
pour l'émission l'a pas du tout non mais
tout est sous contrôle
ces derniers vous est jamais arrivé sans
le téléphone comme à bouaké centre a
commencé parce qu'on sentait nu non mais
vous préférez vous volent vos fiches
plutôt que votent pas mais j'ai eu des
fiches
ça ne sert pas du tout les
comment
il va le dire même de rien à chaque
phrase
[Applaudissements]
ne déroge pas moi ça ne me dérange mais
c'est quoi l'histoire c'est qui ce
numéro qui m'a planté qui
met en bastide à soum acheter ni la roma
merci
[Applaudissements]